das weltraumteleskop hubble ist wirklich
der star der astronomie es ist quasi
unser auge mal und liefert uns
mittlerweile bereits seit 30 jahren
immer wieder neue spektakuläre einblicke
ins universum doch sein ende ist
vorprogrammiert und auch ein möglicher
nachfolger steht schon fest und der wird
spektakulär absolut spektakulär und er
wird unsere sicht auf die welt verändern
im wahrsten sinne des wortes klicks um
science in future geht es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
dann verpasst er nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
pixum gibt es übrigens auch auf die
ohren als podcast die links zu spotify
und im podcast sind unten in der video
beschreibung am 24 april 1990 war das
hubble weltraumteleskop in die
erdumlaufbahn gestartet damit begann
seine erfolgsgeschichte denn es sind
nicht nur farbenprächtige aufnahmen
kosmische phänomene die wir haben zu
verdanken haben
dabei waren auch zahlreiche super
wichtige spektakuläre und überraschende
erkenntnisse für astronomie teams
weltweit habe hat es uns beispielsweise
ermöglicht die ausdehnung und das alter
des universums zu bestimmen auch
spannende infos zu verfahren und der
dunkle materie hat uns hubble beschert
durch habe gab es bestätigung darüber
dass gigantische schwarze löcher in den
zentren von galaxien sitzen und sich der
kosmos immer schneller ausdehnt diese
ausdehnung geschwindigkeit konnte zudem
mit nie zuvor erreichter genauigkeit
bestimmt werden dazu der us-forscher
steve mac welt seit dem start des
hubble-weltraumteleskops im jahr 1990
hat dieses großartige observatorium
unserer augen für die wunder des kosmos
geöffnet und eine neue ära der
astronomie astrophysik und
planetenforschung eingeläutet das alles
wird möglich durch die einzigartige
kombination aus breiten spektrum und
sehschärfe von seinem orbit aus rund 560
kilometer über der erdoberfläche kabel
in die tiefen des alls blicken und das
ohne von atmosphärischen störungen
beeinträchtigt zu werden
dazu kommt die fähigkeit durch exakte
steuerung und die kommen
zahlreiche aufnahmen gigantische bilder
zu machen die hunderten hd bildschirm
entsprechen
die bandbreite seiner optik ist enorm
habe kann somit nicht nur die
energiereiche strahlung heißt gasnebel
anfangen sondern auch durch verhüllende
staubwolken blicken
diese kombination macht hubble
einzigartig bis heute dabei handelt es
sich eigentlich um ein normales
spiegelteleskop dass sie doch weit über
der stirn atmosphäre positioniert ist
zudem sind seine optischen instrumenten
äußerst geschickt kombiniert und das
führt zu seiner ausserordentlichen
präzision und scharf sich jedes optische
instrument bekommt hier einen festen
anteil des lichts so können alle
gleichzeitig aktiv seien ein deutlicher
unterschied zu vielen anderen teleskopen
leben nicht verschiedene daten derselben
objekts zu ein und demselben zeitpunkt
sammeln können
besonders wichtig der primär spiegel
doch dessen herstellung war nicht ohne
denn seine krümmung musste perfekt
stimmen damit überhaupt sein scharfes
bild geliefert werden kann
die oberfläche des spezialglas dürfte
dabei nicht um mehr als 1 800
tausendstel von der perfekten kurven
abweichen und so dauerte sein schleifen
achtung ein ganzes jahr
zum vergleich hätte der spiegel den
durchmesser der erde wären gerade einmal
18 zentimeter erlaubt auf den erd-
durchmesser
doch dann das problem dass das habe
projekt fasst scheitern ließ nachdem das
teleskop schon im orbit war mussten die
fachleute eine erschreckende erkenntnis
machen der primär spiegel war zwar genau
dafür aber falsch geschliffen 4
mikrometer zum flach vergleichbar also
mit einer hornhautverkrümmung doch
obwohl das wirklich nur eine mini
winzige abweichung darstellt stellte
dieser fehler ein riesiges problem dar
denn das licht traf nicht mehr
fokussiert auf die brenn ebene
hubbles blick war verzerrt und die
ersten bilder unscharf für diesen
sehfehler entwickelten die fachleute
dann eine art brille ein system aus
neben spiegeln wurde installiert um
diese abweichung zu korrigieren hört
sich alles leichter an als gesagt denn
das instrument mit der bezeichnung
co-star korrekte
optics space telescope axial replacement
muss er ja erst einmal in den orbit
gebracht werden um dort am teleskop
montiert zu werden
ein space shuttle flug deshalb zum
teleskop und astronauten bauten das
system in stundenlangen außeneinsätzen 1
doch die ganze mühe hat sich gelohnt so
sah ein bild vor heraus und so nach der
reparatur
heute ist die brille längst nicht mehr
notwendig mit der zeit kamen neue
optische instrumente dazu die hbc fehler
korrigieren
denn immer wieder flogen missionen mit
dem space shuttle zum hubble
weltraumteleskop und verbesserten seine
leistung eines der ersten spektakulären
bilder gelangen habe fünf jahre nach
seinem start die rede ist vom ersten
sogenannten hubble deep field durch eine
lange belichtung wurde das bild möglich
dass tausende von galaxien zeigt und
außerdem auch einen blick in die
vergangenheit so wurde es astronomie
teams also quasi direkt vor augen
geführt wie galaxien entstehen doch
nicht nur das hat hubble uns ermöglicht
sondern auch gezeigt dass albert
einstein recht hatte es geht um den
sogenannten gravitationslinseneffekt
einfach gesagt große massen lenken licht
ab und genau das hatte schon albert
einstein mit seiner allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie vorhergesagt
deutlich zu erkennen ist dass auf dem
bild namens happy face es handelt sich
hier vielleicht um eines der schönsten
himmelsobjekte überhaupt und zwar ein
stück rechts unterhalb des kastens des
großen wagens ein strahlendes gesicht
tatsächlich handelt es sich bei den
augen um zwei gelblich leuchtenden
galaxien in rund 4,5 milliarden
lichtjahren entfernung die teil eines
massereichen galaxien haufen sind klar
ist dahinter versteckt sich wohl eine
galaxie die bläulich leuchtet mehrere
bläuliche bogenförmige bilder umgeben
einen galaxienhaufen von
gravitationslinsen effekt ist die rede
weil die lichtstrahlen der weit
entfernten galaxien von der
anziehungskraft des galaxienhaufens
abgelenkt werden und es gibt weitere
äußerst spektakuläre bilder
die haben uns in den vergangenen 30
jahren geliefert hat platz fünf riesen
spiralgalaxien gc 2 885 eine echte
godzilla galaxie diese hubble entdeckung
ist nur
wenige monate her die nasa hatte hier
die möglicherweise größte bekannte
galaxie im leeren universum aufgespürt
deswegen auch der spitzname godzilla
galaxie der offizielle name dieser
galaxie allerdings laut und ug2 85 was
wir bislang über sie wissen 232
millionen lichtjahre von uns entfernt
und 2,5 mal so breit wie die milchstraße
also zweieinhalb mal so breit zudem
beherbergt sie zehnmal so viele sterne
wie die milchstraße fachleute weltweit
wollen jetzt herausfinden wie diese
galaxie so groß werden konnte
platz vier pillars of creation was für
ein bild diese entdeckung des
hubble-weltraumteleskops gelangt
pünktlich zum 25 geburtstag also vor
fünf jahren hierbei handelt es sich
möglicherweise um die merkwürdigste
struktur im sichtbaren universum die
fachleute der nasa und esa haben ihr den
namen pillars of creation gegeben
übersetzt heißt das soviel säulen der
schöpfung sie liegen 6500 lichtjahre von
der erde entfernt in ihrem inneren
entstehen aus staubpartikeln und
gasförmiger interstellarer materie immer
wieder neue sonnenähnliche sterne
es handelt sich also quasi um den
kreißsaal der sterne platz 33 ex nebel
bei dem dreiecks nebel handelt es sich
um die drittgrößte spiralgalaxien der
sogenannten lokalen gruppe nach der
milchstraße und dem andromeda nebel habe
gelangen hier das bislang
detailreichsten bild dieser
nachbargalaxien unserer milchstraße
es hat 665 millionen pixel und wurde von
einem münchener forschungsteam aus 54
einzelaufnahmen zusammengesetzt
diese spiralgalaxien enthält 40
milliarden sterne und einige aktive
stern fabriken bei guten bedingungen ist
sie sogar mit dem bloßen auge als
milchiges fleckchen zu erkennen
fachleute wollen das bild nutzen um so
genannte sternentstehungsgebiete in der
kleinen spiralgalaxien genauer zu
analysieren
platz zwei der pferdekopf nebel das bild
zum pferdekopf nebel wurde zum 23
jahrestag von hubble veröffentlicht es
handelt sich um eine so genannte dunkle
wolke leuchten des interstellaren gas
erhebt sich in form eines pferdekopfs
habe gelang eine spektakuläre infrarot
aufnahme des gas und staub
der in sichtbarem licht kaum zu erkennen
ist doch die infrarot aufnahme offenbar
sogar feine strukturen im gas des nebels
die sich hinter dem staub verbergen denn
er selbst hat sich nach ansicht der
fachleute durch eine zusammenstürzenden
wolke interstellare materie gebildet
ein heißer stern in direkter nähe bringt
ihn zum leuchten um den pferdekopf herum
hat sich die gaswolke allerdings bereits
aufgelöst forschende gehen davon aus
dass sich auch der pferdekopf selbst in
etwa fünf millionen jahren aufgelöst
haben wird platz eins kosmisches riff
diese wunderschöne aufnahme die die
ganze farbenpracht des kosmos
verdeutlicht schenkt uns habe zu seinem
diesjährigen jubiläums es handelt sich
um ein porträt das riesen nebels ngc
2014 und seines nachbarn sng 2020 die
blaue struktur die teil der großen
magellanschen wolke sind eine galaxie
die unsere milchstraße begleitet das
ganze erinnert ein wenig an eine
spektakuläre unterwasserwelt und
deswegen gaben die fachleute ihm den
spitznamen kosmisches riff im rechten
teil des bildes in der südlichen region
entstehen in gas- und staubwolken neue
sterne unten links das blaue objekt
zeigt einen einzelnen massereichen stern
der sich dem ende seiner existenz nährt
er ist 200.000 mal heller als die sonne
solche nebel solche aufnahmen gibt es
erst seit hape der absolute wahnsinn
doch trotz dieser spektakulären erfolge
ist klar dass es mit hubble nicht ewig
so weitergehen wird sein ende ist
vorprogrammiert nicht nur die extremen
bedingungen im welt setzen hatte zu
außerdem auch die schwerkraft etwa
anderthalb kilometer sinkt das
weltraumteleskop pro jahr in 17 jahren
2037 dann wird habe soweit abgesagt sein
dass es in die atmosphäre eintritt
die nasa fachleute wollen dann
entscheiden wie es konkret mit hubble zu
ende geht zur auswahl steht entweder ein
kontrollierter absturz oder aber das
parken in einem höheren stabilen orbit
letzteres könnte mit hilfe einer
unbemannten sonde passieren beide
maßnahmen sollen verhindern dass
trümmerteile auf bewohnte regionen
stürzen label würde aufgrund seiner
größe nicht komplett in der atmosphäre
verglühen
dazu der nasa mitarbeiter dan brown wenn
die zeit gekommen ist
werden wir entscheiden welche methode
eingesetzt wird solange die hardware
funktioniert werden wir aber habe weiter
betreiben und es ihnen ermöglichen
weiter wissenschaftliche daten zu
liefern doch es gibt einen nachfolger
wir haben immer mal wieder darüber
berichtet dass james webb space
telescope vst
möglicherweise könnten dieses riesen
weltraum teleskop mit seiner hundertfach
besseren auflösung als habe die
astronomie komplett revolutionieren
es wurde unter anderem speziell dafür
entwickelt außerirdisches leben zu
suchen anders als das hubble teleskop
das im sichtbaren nahen ultravioletten
und nahen infraroten spektrum sucht ist
das ja ein supertalent im infraroten
bereich so kann es beispielsweise die
atmosphäre von exoplaneten analysieren
die wiederum hinweise auf planet ares
leben gibt die satelliten und teleskope
die wir derzeit zur verfügung haben sind
dafür einfach nicht leistungsstarken
aber nicht nur dass fachleute erwarten
unglaubliche aufnahmen und erkenntnisse
zu sternen und planeten system und
zuletzt könnte das riesenteleskop auch
dazu beitragen endlich auch dem
mysteriösen rätsel
der dunkle materie auf die spur zu
kommen doch die historie von jbl osc ist
geprägt von misserfolgen ursprünglich
sollte das weltraumteleskop schon 2014
mit einer ariane-5-trägerrakete staaten
doch der bau des teleskops wurde
aufgrund der enormen kosten unterbrochen
dann wurden technische mängel
festgestellt zuletzt im sommer 2008 10
da fiel bei vibrations- tests auf dass
einige schrauben locker waren und so
wurde der neue starttermin vom mai 2020
auf den 30 märz 2021 verlegt und der ist
jetzt auch zumindest fraglich wegen
corona konnte zeitweise nicht weiter am
teleskop gearbeitet werden wann wir also
die ersten spektakulären aufnahmen sehen
werden steht in den sternen im wahrsten
sinne des wortes die nasa hatte
vergangenen jahres verkündet dass vor
allem die supernova 1987 asl 19 87
beobachtet werden sollen wenn es denn
dann so weit ist als sie 1987 aufgespürt
wurde handelte es sich um die hälse
supernova seit 400 jahren auch wenn ihr
licht mittlerweile verblasst ist könnten
uns ihre überreste verraten wie sterne
man sterben dazu die nasa mitarbeiterin
oliver jones wir haben keine ahnung
worauf der staub der supernova 19 87 a
besteht web wird uns nicht nur die
zusammensetzung des staubs sondern auch
seine temperatur und dichte des staubes
näher bringen und diese analyse wird
sicherlich folgenreiche erkenntnis mit
sich bringen den staub spielt eine
wesentliche rolle bei der entwicklung
der nächsten generation von sternen
planeten und auch galaxien doch klar ist
auch dass das jbl usc habe nicht
komplett ersetzen kann
denn es deckt nicht die volle bandbreite
von hubbles instrumenten ab die leistung
und auflösung von hubble im
ultravioletten und sichtbaren licht kann
seinen nachfolger nicht ersetzen doch es
gibt einen weiteren plan der laut juwi
optical internet sowie luca übersetzt
also so viel wie großer vermesser im
ultravioletten sichtbaren und infraroten
bereich bislang handelt es sich nur um
einen plan doch gewagt könnte wie das
hubble-weltraumteleskop vielseitig
eingesetzt werden doch es steht noch
eine finanzierungszusage aus wenn diese
aber erfolgt könnte die entwicklung
zeitnah beginnen dann wäre dieses
teleskop möglicherweise in den späten
2000 dreißiger jahren am start dann bin
ich jetzt erst mal mega gespannt auf die
ersten aufnahmen des james webb
weltraumteleskop und auf meine eigenen
ich habe mir nämlich hier auch ein
kleines hubble zulegt wie das hubble ist
es ein spiegelteleskop allerdings gibt
es hier keinen sekundär spiegel wie beim
hubble-teleskop sondern das licht fällt
direkt vom hier vorne über den spiegel
ins okular da wird es über einen
umlenkhebel rein gelenk nur hier sind
übrigens also hier immer klar sind die
linsen eingebaut sie bestimmen dann über
die vergrößerung also unbedingt mal bei
instagram vorbeischauen da werde ich
sicher immer mal wieder eine aufnahme
veröffentlichen denn schon mit diesem
teleskop sind spektakuläre aufnahmen
möglich also hier nicht da geht es zu
instagram unbedingt drauf klicken und
abonnieren
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran